who is so many uh who you just you just
mentioned a few disparate facts about
the man yeah he was the person that took
power in 1979 supreme leader of Iran yes
something you mentioned something about
Paris something about being in the 70s
yes what should we know about the guy oh
yeah
who eventually was known as Imam
Khomeini he was kind of promoted to a
even more Sublime position okay okay uh
can we I'm just a million tangents uh I
told her Imam what do these terms mean
well Ayatollah means the
sign of God
in the course of the 19th century or
early 20th century as the religious
establishment gradually lost its
greater presence in the society and
these prominent places in society they
had some kind different inflation in
titles
so they gave themselves a more Grand
titles yeah more adjectives more
adjectives more Grand titers such as
Ayatollah that became a kind of a
highest rank of the religious hierarchy
but it incidentally was in on you know
unofficial hierarchy there was not it's
not like the Chris like Catholic Church
that you have you know Bishops and you
know Federer it was very unofficial
mother and he was an Ayatollah it was
eventually recognized as an Ayatollah he
was in the first Ayatollah no no no not
at all the ayatollahs were before him
ever since the beginning of the century
but he was eventually recognized as an
Ayatollah and if I want to study this
way
Ayatollah Khomeini was born in 1900
and in a sense all these tremendous
change that Iran witnessed in the course
of the
20th century was in a sense
materializing this person
he become a mullah of a lower rank went
to the traditional mattresses to the
traditional
centers for the education of the
seminarians
never had a secular education
had a very complex Islamic education on
this one-hand jurisprudence on the other
hand probably a little bit of Islamic
philosophy and mysticism which is
unusual for the Juris for the for the
factory as they call them
this religious Scholars or or legal
Scholars of Islam
and then he in the 1960s
when he was residing in Tehran and
gradually becoming more important
he became a voice of opposition against
the Shah
and the reason for opposition uh in the
1960 early 1960s was the fact that the
shot
carried through a series of
extensive
modernization policies of which the most
important was the land reform
so in effect the land distribution that
took place in the early 60s
removed or weakened greatly that class
of land owners from the ancient from the
19th century
and
he uh Khomeini saw himself as a voice of
that old class
that uh felt that actually declared that
this land distribution is on Islamic
according to the Islamic law
properties
a property is honored and you cannot
just
no matter how much and how large are
these states that the landowning class
has the government has no right to
redistribute it even Among The Peasants
among among the
people who are killing the land
so that was a major issue Shaw also gave
the right of
vote to women
and that also he objected it is that
women should not have a right can we
just Linger on the Islamic law
How firm and clear
is the Islamic law that he was
representing and embodying is this um
codified codified yes that's a good term
yeah that's another issue not only the
hierarchy was unofficial
but also
a Islamic law particularly Shiloh
did not have any
uh codified system
because this religious Authority is
always resisted
becoming under a
umbrella of a more codified system of
Islamic law because they were outside
this state in a sense civil civil law
was in the hand of the religious
establishment they had their own courts
independent of the state but other
matters of legal matters was in the hand
of the government there was a kind of in
de facto division between these two
institutions State versus the religious
establishment
therefore it was not codified so he
could declare that this is unofficial or
I said illegal according to the Islamic
law that you distributed land to the
presence and another mustache or another
religious Authority would say no no it's
perfectly fine because he would has a
different reading of the law so that
being in mind that adds to the
complexity of the picture he in the 1963
there was a period of uprising of the
supporters of Ayatollah Khomeini
that was the turning point in a sense to
try to
politicize the religious
supporters of ayatulate who were loyal
to ital how many and in a sense all the
community of more religiously orientated
against the secular policies of the show
and against of course the dictatorship
of the show so that's where the
religious movement became a political
party in 1963 is the first moment it's a
huge Uprising and the government
suppressed it
but then suppression yes would start to
build of course and he was sent to Exile
he went to najaf which is this great
Center in southern so it became a martyr
on top of this at the Martyr he was
probably even forgotten to some extent
but not it was forgotten for the
for the secular
middle class but not to those supporters
of his who were paying him their dues
because in Islam you would pay dues to
religious leaders you know there's
religious Jews and arms that you put pay
to the Cracker authorities and they
redistribute them among their own
students and so forth so they built
actually a network of loyalty based on
this uh donations and these donations uh
that's received by atolo Khomeini was
very effectively through his network was
distributed even if he was in Exile
asadira
so the 1977 1978
when the situation changed and there was
a little bit of opening
in the political climate
then you saw that Ayatollah Khomeini
starts sending cassette messages that
was his mean of communication the
sending cassettes and cassettes were
sent through the country by his Network
so or declarations and saying first that
we would like to see a greater
democratization and the shark has to
abide by the Constitution of 1907
this is a constitution this is a
democratic system and so forth was he
charismatic well it depends who would
call what do you call charismatic get
the long beard it was kind of a man in
turban and the Gown which was a very
unusual leadership
for people who were much more accustomed
to the civilian clothing or to the
equipments of the Shaw's military
uniforms that he used to wear but I also
mean like he's a man I was able to take
power to become popular sufficiently
popular so like I I would like is it the
ideas is it an accident or is it the man
himself the Charisma or something about
the man that led to this particular
person
basically changing the tide of history
in this part of the world in a way
unexpected all the above that you
mentioned or was it just the beard
no I think though it's beyond the
appearance because the appearance is
greatly helped as you know yeah you know
in the 20th century appearance is
helpful yeah pictures for propaganda for
messaging that's an important factor and
he wasn't uh kind of a adamant
and very severe
in his own positions
he could appear very uncompromising
and he had a sense of confidence
self-confidence
that we truly everybody else lacked
and
he was a man of opportunity
as soon as he would see that
a chance and opportunity would open up
he would jump on it
and that's what he did basically as more
the political space opened the
weaknesses of the Shaw's government
became more evident his indecision
became more evident
his lack of confidence became more
evident
Khomeini managed to move further into
the center of the movement because he
was the only Authority that had this
network of support through the mosques
through the people who paid
homage to him
who followed him because there's a sense
of following
of the religious leader in shiza you are
a follower of this Authority or follower
of that Society
and he's basically created
an environment in which people
looked upon him as a kind of a Messianic
figure yeah that came to save Iran
from what they considered at the time
the problems of uh dictatorship under
the shore
so there's not a suspicion about Islamic
law being the primary law of the
language people had very little sense
that what Islamic law is all about
because the secular education has left
that into the old religious schools this
is not something that ordinary educated
Iranian who goes to the universities is
going to learn and therefore there is a
sense of idealization that there is
something great there that is and there
were quite a number of intellectuals
who also viewed this kind of an idea of
they would refer to as this toxication
that is this civilization of the West
that has brought with it
all the modernity that we see around
ourselves has
enormous Sinister features into it and
it has taken away from us our
authenticity
that was the thing that there is
something authentic that should be
protected and therefore a man and that's
kind of a Garb and appearance
received as a source
for return to this originality of their
own culture authenticity of their own
culture and he perfectly
took advantage of that that's so many
tricky advantage of it and the circular
anti at the expense of everybody else
which he managed in the course of 1979
to 1989 which he passed away died in the
10 years during this period managed to
basically transform
the Iranian Society
to create institutions of the Islamic
Republic
and to acquire himself the position of
the Guardian jurists
that was something completely new it
didn't ever exist
before as a matter of fact as we might
know
the model of governments that a
religious establishment takes over the
states
is unprecedented throughout the course
of Iranian history throughout the course
of the Islamic history I would say this
is the first example and probably the
only example
of a of a regime
that religious establishment that has
always in the course of Iranian history
ever since I would say probably at the
16th century if not earlier
has been always
separate from this state
and always kind of collaborating with
this state in a with a certain tensions
in between the two of them there were
two basically as they would call
themselves the two pillars of stability
in the society
that situation changed for the first
time the religious establishment took
over
the power of this state
and that's at the core of what we see
today as a major issue
for Iranian Society because
these are basically that old balance
between the religion and the state which
was kind of a de facto
uh separation of the authorities of the
two
uh has been violated and now you have
empowered if your theocracy in effect
which of course only in the on the on in
its appearances theocracy deep down it's
a in my opinion is the brutal fascist
regime that it stays in power but it has
the appearance of religion into it so
this is really the story of the
revolution
and as a result of that the Iranian
middle classes greatly suffered it's not
without a reason that you see 4 million
Iranians abroad because basically the
emergence of this new power
gradually
uh isolated or marginalized the secular
middle class who could not survive under
that regime
and gradually moved out
uh in the course of perhaps 30 40 years
up to now Iran has
the largest I think I'm right to say so
has the largest brain drain in any
country in the world it's important to
its population so fascinating that um
how much of a weird Quirk of history is
it that
um that religion
would take hold in a country like does
it have to do with the individual
it seems like if we re ran the 20th
century
uh a thousand times
will we get the uh 79 Revolution
resulting in um Islamic law like less
than
you know one percent of the time it
feels like or no what which percentage
would you put well I think has something
to do
with the very complex nature
of how Iran evolved
over a long period of time since the
16th century that's why
if I would for a moment talk about what
I have written I've written a book
that's called Iran and modern history
and it does not start in the 20th
century it starts in the 16th century
yeah because that's what I have argued
that this complex process that at the
end of the day resulted in what we see
around us today is something that was in
making for a very long time and religion
was a big part of it she and the the the
Messiah complex the exactly the the
longing for this great vision of a great
nation that somehow is
um
the sublime nation that can only be
fully Sublime through uh through
religion or at the time it was thought
that is true religion ever since then
it's disillusionment with that image
yeah or at least a process of this
illusionment the outcome of it is what
we see today basically that process of
40 years is a process of re-adjusting to
the realities of the world
that that great moment of romantic
success of a revolution like most
Revolutions of course that is going to
change Iran and bring this kind of a
moment of greatest led into this great
disappointment so the movement of the
great disappointment in a sense like
most Messianic movements by the way
Mosaic move as a general are always
leading into great disappointments but
what I have here that perhaps should be
added to it that yes it was the
peculiarity of Iran
as a society that had to experience
this eventual
encounter between religion and state
that's something to do with the nature
of Jesus that's just one point that
should be pointed out
most of Sunni Islam don't have that kind
of I say most because there is something
there but Sony Islam in general does not
have that kind of an aspiration for the
coming of a Messianic
uh uh a leader
she's them does
she's I mean it's very shaping
particularly the way that it was set up
in Iran
was a religion that has always this
element of expectation to it
for the coming of this
Messianic leader of course I mean
between parenthesis all societies look
for
Messianic leaders and just look around
us but some societies more than others
there's certain culture it might have to
do with them the Romantic poetry that we
mentioned earlier I mean surely I mean
not to draw to me parallels but the
Soviet Union there is romanticism too
and I mean I don't know there there it
does
maybe idealism
a sense of his savior yeah who would
who would bring you out of the misery
that you are in
and and
always looking for a
for a third party
to solve your
issues that's why probably this movement
has a
particular significance because it
probably doesn't look for a messiah
although I was talking to my brother who
is the historian also and he was saying
perhaps the Messiah of this movement is
that Maasai mini the 22 year old girl
that was killed is to have a market
Messiah who is now leading a movement
which no longer has that
charismatic leadership with it but yes I
would say that
Iran has been the birthplace if I might
say that
of Messianic aspirations
going back to the ancient zoracianism
which is the really the whole system
that you see in major religions or at
least best so-called Western religions
it's abrahamic religions
is parallel or perhaps influenced by
Zoroastrianism in which there is an idea
of uh this world and the other word that
is Hereafter there is an idea of a
judgment at the end of the time
and there is a concept that there is a
moment of Justice
that is going to come with the rise of a
religious or a charismatic figure so
it's a very old phenomenon in Iran very
old and it's time when the game repeated
itself in the course of its history but
never as powerfully
as it happened in 1979 and never in the
form of authority from within the
religious establishment it was always
The Descent movements that were
kind of antinomian they were against the
authority of the uh religious
establishment that changed in the 20th
century
but the revolution 1979 that change is
still with us today what can we just
Linger on um
are there some practical
games of Power that occurred
you know in the way that Stalin took
power and held power in the early days
is there something like this in terms of
the establishment of the Revolutionary
guard and all those kinds of stuff yes
so it's the the Messianic figure that
has some support from the people but uh
does he have to crush his enemies in
competition
certainly did
probably not certainly not as brutal in
terms of the victims as you would see in
Soviet Union understand
who the Bloodshed or the
destruction of the population was far
greater
than what you would find in
Iran of the Islamic Republic it's
uncomfortable
perhaps I would find a greater parallel
with Mark zedung
and
particularly because China has a very
strong Messianic tradition
since the ancient times so they have
something and Mao appeared as the kind
of a Messianic figure
there I can see there is a parallel but
also you can see with any other
authoritarian regime with the Messianic
fear at the head of it that it destroys
all the other forces so during the
course of the first 10 years of the
Islamic revolution it destroyed the
liberal nationalists
secular
it's destroyed
the Guerrilla movements some of them
Islamic some of them marxists who turned
into political parties or tendencies in
the course of the post-revolution 1979
they were completely destroyed
and in a very brutal fashion
and uh the their opposition even within
the religious establishment because it
wasn't a uniform there were many
different Tendencies those that were
opposed to the authority of Ayatollah
Khomeini or not Imam Khomeini meaning
almost the sacred
religious figure above the level of a
religious Authority he's a saint kind of
a figure he says she's them has this
idea of imams there were 11 of them the
12th is hidden and would come back at
the end of the time this is okay
Messianic figure
so the title that was always used for
them only in shiza never used for any
other person
he is the first person in the revolution
of 1979 first referred to as Deputy of
Imam
but the term Deputy gradually
disappeared and he became Imam Khomeini
this is that his official title I love
human beings so much
it's so beautiful these uh titles that
we give each other it's um but it's
marvelous stuff you love it because you
haven't been under that system no I I
love it in a way I love it in a very
dark dark
kind of way it caricatures itself it's
it's almost funny in its absurdity if
not for the evil that it has led to in
human history uh but also the fact that
it's a man is in fact fulfillment in a
kind of completely
um unintended fashion is a fulfillment
of that idea of a messiah that they've
been fighting for this Imam which is in
ahide for a thousand years is here and
not here
and therefore Khomeini would have in
effect fulfilled those anticipations but
beyond that I just give you one example
I know that we may have other concerns
but
when I say elimination
at the end of the Iran Iraq War
by the direct order of Ayatollah
Khomeini a fatwa that he wrote a group
of prisoners
who belong to a variety of uh
political parties the left religious
left
majority of them
the left and the the Marxist left and
the religious left
in a matter of a few weeks or perhaps a
few months I'm not actually quite sure
about the times that
uh in a series of these were people who
have already been tried
and they were given uh sentences
they were brought back
before the uh
summary Trials of three judges or more
three four of them one of them is now
the
new president of the Islamic Republic
and they were given a a quick summary
sentences which meant uh execution
so something between probably six to
eight thousand
were executed in matter of a month or
two months something like that
mostly in Tehran but also in provinces
um and that remained an extraordinary
trauma
for the families for those who had these
kids in they're all young all young
so this remains very much uh
kind of original sin of the Islamic
Republic
that cannot get rid of and it's in
people's memories they didn't allow them
even the families
to go and mourn
their dead
in a an official symmetry which they
created for them now the latest thing is
that they put a huge concrete wall
around it so nobody would be able to get
into it
so these all part of this extraordinary
level of
level of
atrocity
brutality that you see that the regime
claimed that it comes with the morality
of religion and Islam to bring back the
justice and and and be more
uh in a sense kind to people ended up
with what it is in the memory of many of
the people in Iraq so developing these
fascistic attendance very much
destroying minorities Baha'is one of
them
hundreds of Baha'is were without any
reason without any involvement were
picked up and
executed the properties were taken over
their rights were taken away from them
even up to this day this is the largest
by the very religious minority in Iran
so you would see that in many areas
this is a acts very much as an Beyond
Authority and it's a kind of really a
fascistic regime